It's presidents week here on the Rubin
report and we're partnering with learn
liberty to bring you five shows in five
days each highlighting a different
president of the United States.
Joining me today is an associate
professor of history at Sam Houston
state and the Co author of JFK and the
Reagan Revolution,
a secret history of American prosperity.
Brian,
to be attributed.
Welcome to the Rubin report.
It's great to bear to Mitrovich
Demetrihevic.
Usually I say it with a hard state.
Demetrihevic Demetrihevic.
Okay.
I was a big fan of draws in Petrovich
who was a basketball player from Croatia
and the in the early nineties,
but some people said Petro Vic,
and I could never tell rudy.
Tom.
Johnny bench the old coach.
Yeah.
That's properly hot.
Check at the city,
so I'm heretical.
Rudy Times daughters.
That 95 Houston Rockets.
Steam is my favorite basketball team of
all time.
Clyde Drexler right there.
There you go.
As a Houston guy that has.
That has meaning to you.
All right.
I could talk basketball the entire time,
but let's talk president by the title of
your book.
We could probably talk about Reagan just
as easily as we could.
Talk about JFK,
who we're going to talk about.
Um,
do you have a,
do you have a preference out of those
two?
Well,
our book JFK in the Reagan Revolution
really is two thirds,
three quarters about John F Kennedy
because we've forgotten that John F
Kennedy paved the way for the Reagan
revolution and this big
tax cut.
Alright,
so jfk,
since he spent two thirds of it on JFK,
that's the guy we're going to talk
about.
Um,
I find with JFK that what it seems that
most,
at least younger people know,
say under 45 ish,
50 ish,
something like that.
They know a lot about the assassination.
You know,
history channel runs the documentaries
all the time.
You can watch the movie,
JFK,
a zillion other,
uh,
things that are out there,
but there's obviously a lot more to jfk
than,
than just the unfortunate ending.
So let's,
let's start at the beginning.
What do we need to know about early
childhood,
the Kennedy family,
et Cetera?
Terry,
let's start with childhood.
Sure.
It'll.
John F Kennedy was born in May of 1917
in a very,
uh,
important family,
a family that was becoming one of the
richest in the United States.
His father,
Joseph p Dot Kennedy,
at that point in the teens that
graduated from Harvard about 10 years
before,
was building his fortune would within
Kennedy's a young childhood before he
turned 15.
I'm his father had become one of the
richest men in the country.
And actually just a peak.
Kennedy made most of his money in what
we call the great contraction,
the worst period of American economic
history from 1929 to 1933 when he short
sold the market.
And that's really when the Kennedy's
became,
uh,
the one of the top richest families in
the United States.
So how political was the Kennedy family
at that time?
Yeah,
I mean,
it was pretty political.
Joseph p Dot Kennedy.
John F Kennedy's father had married the
daughter of an important Boston
politician.
And then Joseph p was not involved in
politics until FDR.
Franklin Roosevelt appointed him the
first head of the Securities and
Exchange Commission in 1934.
And then he became a big Roosevelt
Democrat.
So that was the sort of beginning of
the dynasty in the Kennedy name.
Yes.
Yeah.
So Jfk then tell me a little bit about
sort of his evolution from a young
person to starting to become a
politician.
Yeah.
So John Jfk was the second son,
so there was the Joseph Kennedy junior
who would be killed in World War II and
he wasn't a good student in prep school
and he went to Princeton actually for a
semester.
It didn't do well there.
Then went to Harvard,
did not do particularly well until his
senior year,
probably plagiarized his thesis,
which then somehow sold 80,000
competence as a book when it was
published.
But with his father's help.
Really.
Wait,
are you telling me a little more about
that?
I haven't heard that one.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
So,
uh,
John F Kennedy,
his father in 1938,
39.
I guess this would have been at that
point was the ambassador to the court of
St James.
So it was the US ambassador to Great
Britain and was very interested in the
United States fighting the Soviet Union
and not necessarily fighting Nazi
Germany.
Uh,
and so that kind of caused diplomatic
problems with FDR foreign policy,
but JFK had extraordinary access to the
files.
And so he wrote a thesis that was
probably substantially ghost written
about how England was dealing with the
Germany credits and then,
and then it was published as a book and
it sold about 80,000
copies.
Of course,
Kennedy would publish another book,
profiles in courage and Joseph,
he would pull string.
So at one of the Pulitzer,
it's good to come from a family.
It is pretty good.
Uh,
so tell me a little bit more about how
he then decided to get into about in
development.
Yeah.
Well,
I,
the decisive event really was the death
of his brother in 1944.
Joseph Kennedy Jr,
uh,
killed in World War II because really
all the hopes were on,
on this son.
And he apparently was a very impressive
guy.
If you look at old pictures of the sun,
Joe,
he was even way better looking than JFK.
He was kind of bigger.
JFK was always kind of skinny,
uh,
and it really devastated the father when
he was killed in the war and they
realize,
Oh boy,
Jack is going to be the one where we're
going to have all these political hope
son.
And the father did not have high hopes
for Ted at that point to Robert Robert,
maybe a.
But right after Kennedy got out of the
war,
of course he had his distinguished
career too.
He ran for Congress in 1946.
His father pulled a lot of strengths and
he won a seat in Brookline,
Massachusetts teams in the US House.
What does Paul a lot of strings mean
because I just find the dynasty part of
this fascinating.
The idea that they're sort of moving
children,
that the power elite can sort of help
people get into play here.
Well,
pull out a strings in the 1946 election,
for example.
So on the ballot,
Kennedy was running against a particular
opponents.
His father found somebody else with the
exact same name and put that guy's name
on the ballot and then had a whole
publicity campaign for that guy's name.
I forget the exact name,
uh,
to be voted for so that,
that would split the vote.
That takes a lot of money and a lot of
kind of,
um,
a naked ambition.
So that's an example of the kind of
hardball,
but he felt pled.
So that's a slight sidebar when you hear
about all the craziness involved in
politics these days and everyone.
No,
it's never been worse and listened to
the way people talk and all that.
It's like a lot of shady stuff has been
going on for a long time.
Well,
I have no idea how we could look at,
say,
the McCarthy era,
both how mccarthy was treated and how
mccarthy treated others and say that
politics was warm and fuzzy back in the
forties and the fifties.
I have no idea how we could say that.
Yeah.
So did JFK,
do you think he had a presidential
aspirations then when he started this?
This was sort of thrust on him and he
and he became a congressman.
But was he already thinking about that,
do you think?
I,
I think so in that,
um,
it was well understood that,
that Joe Jr was going to be something
like president of the United States.
And so when that could not happen after
his death,
I think it'd be,
became pretty clear to the sons.
Uh,
so there was still jack,
Robert and teddy left and then I think
six girls that they had to take,
take that place.
And so when he ran for Congress,
yeah,
I mean it was to go onward and upward.
So he was a congressman.
How many years was he a congressman?
Right up until he ran from.
He was a US representative from
Brooklyn,
Massachusetts from from 46 to 52.
And then he won a US Senate seat in
Massachusetts,
bucking the eisenhower a trend because
he ran on the democratic side.
So he was one of the few democratic
victories in the 1952 elections.
So then he was a senator for eight years
before he became president.
Yeah.
Did he have any major accomplishments as
a senator?
Well,
that's the interesting thing because
when we asked what were his major
accomplishments as president,
let's say legislatively really comes
down to maybe one or two,
the tax cut in the civil rights act,
so there's not a lot of major
accomplishments and the whole Kennedy
biography.
The funny thing about his career as a
legislator in the Senate in particular,
this is big enthusiasms for two things.
Number one,
he was going after the mob,
which then his son route his brother
Robert would be big on and number two is
an anti communist in foreign policy and
that that's how we distinguish himself
as a senator.
Yeah,
so it's interesting that the
anticommunist part is interesting
because the parties have shifted so much
these days that I'm not saying the left
or the Democrats are communists now,
but that voice,
that sort of anti socialism,
communism voice would rarely be heard of
from the lottery left,
which does tell you how these things
have shifted.
Joseph p dot Kennedy,
his father became persona non grata in
the U.
S government,
when in 1938,
39,
he told Franklin,
d dot Roosevelt from his high position
as ambassador in Great Britain.
We don't have to worry about the Nazis
so much.
We have to worry about communism because
communism can overthrow the American way
of life.
I think there's a pretty direct link
there to what his son was doing in the
fifties and sixties.
That's interesting.
So he was,
he viewed it as Nazi-ism was an external
threat,
not within our borders,
but communism actually with something
that could come from.
That was joe's feeling.
Yeah.
It was Kinda Kinda prophetic.
And he was a new dealer and all that.
You said,
well,
new deal.
The new deal can help save capitalism.
That was an erroneous argument.
But,
but Joseph p dot Kennedy was worried
about the onslaughts against capitalism.
Communism.
Yeah.
Interesting.
So it sounds like the Senate career was
sort of less than spectacular.
It doesn't sound like anything major
happened.
Kennedy was pretty careful.
Uh,
he,
he began his Senate career,
uh,
ailing.
He had back surgery in 1953.
As soon as he became a senator and could
not attend the Senate,
he was in fact had to be reclined,
uh,
for a very long time because his back
injury and that's when he decided to
write profiles and courage,
his 1956 book,
1955 when the Pulitzer in 1956 about the
greats of the Senate over time.
So because he was incapacitated,
he wanted to show he was still doing
senate work by writing about Senate
history.
Right?
Yeah.
God,
what a beautiful thing to be in
government.
You don't really have to do anything and
you could write about the other guys
that did some stuff.
It's,
it's an incredible thing.
Nineteen 60,
he becomes president and he defeats
Richard Nixon who was vice president at
the time.
I think the one thing that people really
remember is that debate.
Oh yeah.
Because he was sort of this young good
looking guy and there was Nixon
sweating.
Is there anything else we have to
remember from,
from that election?
So yeah,
that.
So I,
there was debate in September 19,
60 and people always say that Nixon won
on the radio and lost on televisions,
that if people just heard his words or
even read the transcript,
that he defeated Kennedy.
But if you looked on the television,
there's black and white television and
lots of viewers.
A Kennedy was the youthful,
a bronze,
which is probably from his Addison
Syndrome,
not the Suntan,
a hero in Nixon looked like a schlub.
Uhm,
I dunno
because it was in black and white,
but it's still even having.
Okay.
Still helps.
And again,
that was from one of his ailments.
I mean that wasn't from the South
Pacific.
So I dunno,
I've read those transcripts and I think
Kennedy clearly won.
I mean Nixon was saying things like,
oh,
there's been great economic growth in
this country.
We're tipping into a recession,
right?
Then 400,000
people.
We're about to lose their jobs in the
month of October.
And Nixon was saying,
oh,
we've had the greatest economic growth
with that we've ever had under
Eisenhower.
Been three recessions under Eisenhower.
Now.
I think Nixon lost that debate on the
transcript as well.
Interesting.
So just to get a sense of how parties
have changed,
what was the,
what were the basic tenants that a jfk
was running on?
Yup.
So John F Kennedy didn't know what he
wanted to run on a.
This is a classic Kennedy thing.
We know we must be president.
So the question is what are we to run?
Uh,
uh,
so,
it was really the Democratic National
Committee or the,
the,
the convention that summer that kind of
defined for Kennedy.
He had a lot to do with it of course,
at what the,
what he would run on.
And he decided he would run the on,
that the country was not growing enough
and he made his tagline,
we have to get this country moving
again.
We have all these old slow people in
government and he kept making the point
that we have a lot of recession.
So it was right.
There was a recession,
1954 big one in 1957 and then it was
coming right then in 1960 and he said we
got to get out of this Rut,
and he kept saying we have to get this
country moving again,
get this country moving again.
So that was his main thing.
And then he also talked about after we
helped,
we have to get a little tougher on
communism because we're not moving
enough.
The Soviets are starting to pass us by
and those were his big themes.
So when you say that within a 20,
18 context,
it's hard to believe,
as I referenced earlier,
it's hard to believe that a Democrat
would be running against sort of slow,
inefficient government,
but that is what he did.
It's kind of incredible.
Yeah.
Now the Republicans back then were the
big deficit hawks there are like,
okay,
maybe we've had some recessions,
but we have a budget deficit.
Then we have to keep taxes high tax
rates high,
so we take care of the budget deficit.
Wouldn't be prudent or that'll George
Bush line.
I mean that's very applicable.
George Bush came of age in the 19
fifties to have economic growth if we
don't take care of our deficit first.
And that was the defensive position.
Avantis and Howard and Nixon.
Kennedy saw that and saw an opening and
ran with it.
Yeah.
So what was the beginning of the
presidency like when I watch all of
these documentaries now,
you know,
they talk so much about the family and
that there was this feeling of this
young person in the office and all of
that.
I suspect there was more to it than just
Okay.
So when Kennedy was elected in November
19,
60,
the United States that just tipped into
a recession and there were mass layoffs
and hundreds of thousands in October
probably delivered in the election when
that Sorenson has advised with certainly
thought.
So and then unemployment went all the
way up,
increased up to $5 million by night by
January 1961.
So when you kind of,
you know what that percentage was just
for reference to five percent now it
doesn't sound like that.
What will 5 million,
5 million the workforce,
the unemployment rate was probably going
up to about eight percent at that point
I'd have to check,
but probably around there.
Um,
so Kennedy took office,
submits a snow storm of,
right.
That just ended it before his inaugural
address,
famous inaugural address.
And the big problem was there's now a
new recession and then when he gave his
State of the Union address 10 days later
in January of 1961,
um,
he kind of had a lot of kind of
equivalence equivocal statements.
He said we have to get our house in
order.
We have yet our country moving again and
we have,
the government has to spend a lot of
money.
So we kind of laid out two options.
We have to kind of get the government
more efficient but also get the
government spending a lot of money.
So it was unclear what he was going to
do.
Yeah.
What does that even mean?
I mean,
do you think he knew at the time because
those sound like statements that can't
work together.
Richard Reeves,
who's his greatest biographer,
he wrote the great book on Kennedy in
Nineteen Ninety two.
President Kennedy.
He said,
no,
no.
What Kennedy liked to do,
and I think this is true,
we have all the Kennedy tapes.
We can hear him on audio that John F
Kennedy Library has an amazing things
online.
We can hear so much from Kennedy's voice
privately.
It's pretty clear that he thought
himself kind of the Uber intellectual.
I'm not a philosophical intellectual,
but somebody who could process thoughts
and he would get a lot of good advice
and then pick the best option.
So that's the way he would operate.
He wasn't gonna figure it out himself.
He was going to wait and see and then
make a strategic decision.
So you think when he brought up those
seemingly conflicting ideas that he
actually did mean it and that eventually
you could pick one.
You would whittle it away with the right
people behind it.
And now this sort of gets to what your
book was about.
Which one did he end up going for?
It was this good.
He went for both.
Okay.
So Larry Kudlow and I wrote this book a
Jeff Can,
the Reagan Revolution about the John F
Kennedy tax cut.
And the big reason is what Larry,
my co author has had to deal with for
15,
20 years.
He gets this at parties from the likes
of people like Caroline Kennedy.
Uh,
he gets it on television and CNBC.
How dare you say that?
The John F Kennedy tax cut had anything
to do with the ragging tax cut because
that tax cut was designed by Keynesians
in order to stimulate demand in the
economy.
And Larry's out.
I don't think so.
And he's right.
All right.
Wait,
let's pause for just a second though.
Can you tell me a little bit about the
tax cut specifically?
So we have the framework.
Okay.
Yeah.
So there was a tax cut in 1964.
So after Kennedy's president of,
after Kennedy died,
that was his brainchild and that
actually was his main legislative
accomplishment,
but he was president for a thousand days
and he didn't get anything done really
on the economy until he introduced that
tax cut in 1963.
So in 61 and 62,
he was doing his famous vacillating.
That's when he was thinking about,
hey,
the canes,
yours is saying we need loose money from
the Federal Reserve and we need a lot of
social programs.
And he was experimenting with that
forecast.
Came in,
there's going to be another recession.
He pulled back and said,
wait,
we need some more deep thinking.
Keynesian said,
keep doing it.
But then pulled in other people.
What do you say?
No,
we need a big marginal tax cut.
I get it.
When the stock market crashed in April
19,
62,
June 19,
he said,
okay,
we need a big marginal tax gut.
How powerful was the presidency at this
time?
You know,
one of the things that we talk about on
this show a lot is just that the
executive branch just keeps getting more
power and more power and does all this
stuff via executive action.
A lot of this,
when you hear about it,
I think the average person thinks,
wait a minute,
is it the president's job really to be
doing all this?
Is it he's supposed to sign.
The law is not really making the laws,
but it's interesting on that score is
the John f Kennedy was actually not
terribly interested in making unique
executive actions actually with each of
his executive sign it signing up
signings.
He had these signing statements that
went on and on and on about how he
justified his signature was sometimes.
Now we did.
They just sign it right now.
It's just no know he paddled up.
Signature back.
So good.
I think that's the residence.
Yeah,
so he actually rejected a,
an executive authority that his liberal
advisors were imploring him to take him
and that was his liberal advantage and
say you should have a standby tax cut
authority.
You should have the authority as
president just to reduce taxes on your
own for a period of time,
maybe up to 18 months.
So if the economy starts tipping into
recession,
you can just sign a piece of paper and
everyone's taxes will go down and we'll
get out of recession.
And then if inflation starts going up or
overheating then you can take it away
and that's effective.
And Kennedy said,
no,
I'm not going to do that.
That's interesting.
So I always described Kennedy as my kind
of Democrat.
You know,
I talk a lot about how the left has sort
of lost its way and it's lost its
classical liberal roots and they've
picked progressivism,
big government over liberalism.
Do you think his political ethos,
I mean,
from everything I'm hearing from you so
far was he basically came from a
classical liberal line of thinking,
right?
Is that,
is that fair to say?
Yeah,
I mean,
Ken Kennedy ultimately
it sounds like there was definitely some
play on both sides.
Yeah.
Kennedy ultimately did some very good
things as precedent above all the tax
code.
You could argue the civil rights act
even though like I still kind of think
and Kennedy believed,
and we can talk about this later if you
like,
that if the tax got,
had just happened,
the civil rights,
that would have been unnecessary.
We can talk about that later.
The thing though about Kennedy's,
he was kind of a wild man.
I mean,
he was a rich wildman and um,
I don't know how useful that
particularly is in our political life.
His father was kind of crazy about what
he did,
how he felt he could influence politics
and his son was kind of a chip off the
old block,
although his son was incapable of making
money unlike his father.
Uh,
but they were both pretty wild people in
kind of in charge of the United States
government.
That might be an argument for shrinking
Yeah.
Well,
all right,
so when you say wild,
I mean we hear all kinds of stories and
rumors and all this and that.
I mean,
what are you,
what are you saying wild is or was?
Yeah.
Um,
we at Larry and I talked a bit about a
girl.
He dated,
a woman named Margaret [inaudible] who
won the Pulitzer Prize in biography and
history sort of biography,
a great biography of John Calhoun,
1950.
And when the pills surprise then Kenny
wanted to get to network because he
wanted to win,
appealed surprise too.
And we have her recollections of the
time when she dated Kennedy right before
he,
um,
he proposed to Jackie in 1953 and she
said,
you know,
he'd just drive around in the convert
convertible and making sure he was
staying on the street car tracks and
just annoying people on the road.
And he was saying,
I want to do this,
I'm going to do this.
I just realized this guy's just a little
bit out of my league.
Um,
he was a force of nature.
so all right,
there are some people who are forces of
nature.
So I just think from a certain
perspective that might be a reason if we
have government to make sure that if we
have those people at the top of
government,
government should be small.
All right.
I want to do a lot on the taxes and I do
want to
get to civil rights,
but we should back up a little bit
because I haven't mentioned Jackie at
all.
I actually just watched the movie with
Natalie Portman.
I thought it was excellent.
What do we need to know about their
relationship,
the courtship.
And then the amount of power that she
had,
or at least the uncomfortability with,
with being the first lady,
and then subsequently after,
after he was assassinated,
Jackie,
I'm the first guy who proposed to Jack.
He just died a year or two ago in his
home on Nantucket in Massachusetts.
And Jackie turned down his proposal.
This is in 1951 or 52,
uh,
because she and her mother did not think
that he would end up being rich enough
and I point out that he'd died on
nantucket.
But I think she was right.
Even he was,
would not have been rich enough.
Well,
um,
no,
I think that Jackie,
and that's hard to believe,
but people don't really understand what
that sort of northeast,
um,
what,
what do you call that?
It's not even a lead.
It's something else,
right?
Just that,
that family dynasty the thing where
these people really were connected with
other people for the purposes of,
of politics and power.
It's hard.
It's hard to believe it.
I think in modern sense.
Um,
but I think what really calm Jackie
down,
they were a great love match.
I don't think there's any dispute about
that Jack and Jackie,
but what really settled Jackie was
Joseph piece wealth.
Jackie really adored Jeff Case.
Father adored him.
Um,
and his $400,000,000
calmed her down.
So I think that was at the absolute glue
that kept them together.
Right.
And she came from a lot of money,
right?
I mean,
the movie has had money.
Yeah.
They,
uh,
then there's a divorce and she was
married and she had brought into the
[inaudible] family,
which was very involved.
The senator from New Jersey,
all class representative who voted for
the Kennedy tax cut in 1960,
19 sixties.
Lewis,
the famous novelist,
um,
but they,
they had been harmed by the 1929 crisis
and the Kennedy family had been
immensely enriched by the 1929 crisis.
So there was a big wealth gap between
those families.
So everything that I've seen about,
or I haven't read much about her,
but I've watched grey gardens,
the Jackie Moody and everything that she
really struggled with the public nature
of this really from day one.
But she also knew what she was marrying
into.
Is that just a little bit about the
complexity of her character?
Well,
Jackie was this.
No question.
She was a sophisticated person.
I mean she spoke French and Spanish and
all that because she was interested in
the ways of the world and she really was
one of the most remarkable fashion
plates in all of history.
And she stepped into those roles very
well.
So yes,
she was shy.
She has that little voice that you can
vary the amount very barely here.
Um,
but she also understood what her
potential was.
Her potential was to be an ambassador
for civilization and she stepped into
that very,
very willingly and it's good that she
did.
Okay.
So now let's jump back,
renew a little more on her,
but then now let's jump back to those
tax cuts.
So you're saying the JFK put those tax
cuts into place 62,
63,
but then they weren't enacted until
after he was gone.
So tell me a little bit more about that.
What happened is they didn't split those
tax cuts in place,
I'm afraid.
And 61 and 62,
he listened to his liberal advisors who
said,
we have to concentrate on government
spending,
hold off on tax cuts.
Let's just concentrate on government
spending.
Let's get loose money from the Fed and
maybe welfare programs spend on national
parks.
I'd post offices all bunch of stuff and
that will stave off for session,
that'll stave it off,
that'll stave it off.
And if we invest in education and
hospitals and Medicare and welfare,
the economy will grow because of that
government investment.
That was the argument of his liberal
advisors.
Kennedy did that for the first year and
a half.
All the forecasts came in and said,
oh,
there's gonna be another recession.
There's been.
There were four recessions.
The 1950 to 1949,
50 4:57
60,
let me a fifth and 13 years.
Every 24 months,
36 months,
it's going to be a recession.
When the stock market went down 30
percent in the spring of 1962,
Kennedy said they made another
recession.
I am going to be so run out of office.
It's not funny.
We're going to switch gears here and
that's when he gave his commencement
speech at Yale in June of 19,
62 saying we have to think about
reversing our policy mix towards tight
money to protect the dollar in tax cuts
to expand the economy,
and then what happened?
What was the result then is liberal
advisors said,
Whoa,
wait,
wait.
It's going great though.
Listen to that.
We're going to do this.
Their argument though,
at that point when they were looking at
the numbers,
what,
what was the argument was purely like
operating on a philosophical level and
then you just keep throwing money at the
government and these programs.
They waves academic articles.
I had,
they had Paul Samuelson at Mit and
Robert Solow to future Nobel prize
winners who was a staff and the council
of economic advisors saying,
Oh no,
we've come up with this thing called the
neoclassical synthesis that says if you
have really loose money from the Fed,
that will get the economy moving.
Don't worry about inflation.
You can mop it up with high tax rates
and then the revenue you get can fund
programs in education,
in healthcare that will help the economy
grow.
It was just stick to.
I forget about those forecasts for
recession,
but that,
that really reveals Kennedy's decision
making character.
He listened,
listened,
and then just said,
okay,
you guys are wrong.
We're going to do the opposite.
And that's,
you know,
that's real decision making metal.
So then aft in 64,
when these tax cuts go into place,
then what was the result?
Well,
so there's still a year and a half
there,
if I may point out.
Yeah,
so then in July,
Kennedy started talking to his treasury
secretary.
Big Time.
Now he had communicated with them daily
on all sorts of matters.
But Larry and I talk a lot about seed
Douglas Dillon,
the unsung hero of the Kennedy
Administration,
Justice Richard Chesapeake Kennedy,
by the way,
I'm Kennedy's treasury secretary.
Dylan said,
you got to protect the dollar and cut
tax rates.
That's what you gotta do.
Kenny went on national television in
August,
saying,
by the way,
that's our policy.
I'm going to introduce the bill in
Congress.
He did that in January of [inaudible].
Sixty three big congressional debate
almost got passed before the
assassination by that point,
the markets and everyone else,
Kennedy serious about tax that and
that's when the huge sixties boom
started.
What did the parties think of this at
the time?
Because if you think about it in the
context of 2018,
the Democrats generally you are for
higher taxes.
Republicans generally are for lower
taxes.
So when Kennedy goes out there and
listens to the advice and says this was
the party behind him,
right?
Or am I looking at this only through our
2018?
No,
no,
this is news.
This bigness.
Larry and I talk about this in the book
a lot.
The party of tax rate cuts particularly
cuts on the top rate of income tax.
The top one.
Now back then it was 91 percent.
That's unbelievable.
It's really hard to fathom.
On a top rate was 91 percent.
It's so hard to fathom that it has to be
a joke and it wasn't true because nobody
paid it.
No,
it's true.
Nobody paid that,
right?
Um,
maybe 20 percent of people who should
been a red should have applied to pay
to.
That's how many loopholes there were.
And the Democrats said,
you see these French guys,
what they're doing is they're buying off
the tax system.
They climb,
they're paying this rate,
and then they get all these loopholes
and they're hiding their money and we
get a recession every 24 months because
capital is not deployed correctly.
So it was the Democrats,
Wilbur Mills,
chairman of House Ways and means
committee in 1959 commissioned a huge
2,500
page study on why we have to cut the top
right of the income tax.
And it was the Republicans who said,
Hey,
hold it.
You know,
we know what to do.
We,
if we say we need a loophole,
give us a loophole.
We're in charge here.
So Republicans said,
no tax rate cuts.
The system's working fun in the
Democrats said,
tax rate cuts to get us out of the
cereal recession.
What does that say about how things flip
over years in time?
Well,
I think first of all,
we have to blame the Contemporary
Democrats,
Democrats today,
the last 20 years.
Um,
what are you doing for getting your
legacy?
I mean,
we can go back to the 18 twenties to
realize that the founding of the party,
it was about lowering top tax rates.
When you talking about the tariff,
John Calhoun and Kennedy had a lot to
say about calhoun through his girlfriend
Margaret.
Quite galloon said,
yet tariff rates hurt the little guy.
And then grover Cleveland income tax
hurts the little guy.
18 nineties woodrow Wilson after a
raised taxes had three treasury
secretaries who said,
these are completely scarifying.
Let's lower them.
They're killing investment in this
country for the little guy.
Really you can go through just about
every Democratic president is cut tax
rates.
I mean,
Bill Clinton cut the capital gains rate.
Jimmy Carter cut the capital gains rate.
Barack Obama was spooked by the
exploration of the Bush tax cuts and he
kept them from one more year.
So,
I mean,
there's a long history of Democrats
getting the top right.
Yeah.
So then,
all right,
so 64.
Now the economy starts going again,
k Kennedy's gone.
Tell me a little bit more about the
legacy of that and then sort of how that
got to Reagan and then we'll get it.
Okay.
Here's the basic,
uh,
inflection.
Here are the basic numbers.
The eight years of the Eisenhower
presidency in 1953 to 1961 economic
growth was two point five percent.
Okay?
That's not good.
Population growth than baby boom was two
point five percent.
This is complete stagnation with three
recessions from 1961 to 1969.
So at the beginning of the candidate
administration,
through the end of the Johnson
economic growth was five point one
percent more than double the rate of
economic growth.
Now we believe it's a highly
attributable Larry and I,
to the policy mix that Kennedy adopted,
which is we are going to guarantee that
dollar.
We're not going to try to get the dollar
off the gold standard and Nixon would.
We're going to guarantee the dollar.
So we're not going to have loose money
from the Fed and we're getting get money
out there by lowering tax rates,
particularly on the rich.
It worked.
It worked as beautifully as any public
policy has ever worked in,
in American history.
All right,
so let's change gears a little bit here
and talk about some of the civil rights
stuff because as all of this is
happening and there's a ton of.
Obviously we're talking about
economically mostly,
uh,
the civil rights movement was,
was happening in,
it's in its best sense.
So I guess first,
what was his innate feelings about the
civil rights movement and we'll talk
about some of the specific.
Yeah,
I think John F Kennedy was in favor of
the civil rights movement.
I think he clearly thought that there
should be equal opportunity and a lot of
the recalcitrance that could be found in
the country,
um,
you know,
was regrettable and should be lifted
when it came to policy though,
he was characteristically slow moving.
So how,
so for example,
like what could he have done earlier,
etc.
Well,
yeah,
I mean now we should note that slow
moving might make sense and that a lot
of civil rights activists argue with
that the laws are already on the books.
I mean there's nothing We need to do
except just be true to ourselves and all
the problems will be lifted you the
freedom rides.
He made phone calls and a birmingham
jail when martin luther king was in the
birmingham crisis in april,
may of 19,
63.
Kennedy wasn't doing a lot aside from
just kind of pressure verbally.
But the funny thing about that is that
what a lot of leaders said in a Philip
Randolph had been saying this for a long
time,
Is that we need jobs.
You know,
civil rights is nice,
but when black unemployment
unemployment's 20 percent and when you
don't have any shackles to rub together
would go to civil rights.
So kennedy started understand,
oh,
if we have a booming economy,
a lot of people in this country,
including whites,
are going to start relaxing and say,
sure,
blacks,
whites,
everything.
Because everyone is well off and that
kennedy perceived.
That's one of the reasons he cut taxes.
So I know I'm going to get some crap for
saying this,
but that almost seems like the trump
view of equality that trump has been
cutting taxes.
Uh,
the,
I think I read just a couple of weeks
ago,
the black unemployment is at an all time
low right now,
so he was sort of taking that.
That's a page from the jfk book.
It is.
And when I talk about the civil rights
act of four $65 and 64 when kennedy
introduced in june of [inaudible] 63 and
it was passed,
um,
I don't know if the tax cut have been
passed.
If we had had a growing economy and five
percent in the fifth days,
would we have even thought to have a
civil rights act?
I don't know because everyone might have
been getting along well enough that
kennedy kind of came to that realization
and that's a real thing.
so if we perceive it today,
we shouldn't run away from it.
That's a,
that's a good association.
Yeah.
It's interesting because I know even
just by saying those two names in the
same sentence,
a certain amount of people that are
going to be angry at me,
but that's all right.
Um,
what,
what was the nature of his relationship
with martin luther king?
Because I've read a bit about it and it
sounds like it was,
it was kind of complex.
There were places where they were lined
up,
but not all the time.
Well,
let me answer it this way.
What was the federal government's
relationship with martin luther king?
Because jagger,
hoover of course,
is still doing his thing,
his fbi director with all the kind of
surveillance,
probably harassment of martin luther
king and kennedy is paralyzed as
everyone is with the fbi.
Um,
so there's that.
I mean,
kennedy is not doing anything about the
kind of harassment
kennedy know about that.
Do we know if kennedy knew that all that
was happening?
I'd have to look at the files.
We have a lot of those remain
classified.
Um,
so I'm not totally sure.
Yeah.
They have declassified some of this
stuff just in the last year,
right?
It's exposed a little bit more of the
surveillance that was happening.
Yeah,
mlk.
right.
But what about their personality
relationship?
Yeah,
I think kennedy appreciated kings,
intellectual ism.
I mean there was kind of.
He brought a king into the white house
and then he,
he watched the march on Washington from
the portico of the white house,
kind of peering around the corner and
then invited everyone back afterwards
and he apparently said,
I wish I could be out there with them
and acted chummy with king,
but he did kind of keep them at arm's
length.
I think he was a little worried about
king's association,
a invidious or not with communism
because kennedy was very anticommunist.
Right.
So that's interesting because a,
from when we're taping this,
it was just a couple of weeks ago that
it was a martin luther king day and I,
you know,
I find it,
it's one of the strangest days to be on,
on twitter.
not that you can garner that much
embraced twitter,
but where everyone's sort of takes mlk
and uses them for their modern day
political purpose.
Right.
So the meme.
So some people saying he was a
socialist,
some people saying he was a communist,
he was an environmentalist,
eat whatever you want him to be within
your 2018 lens.
That's what people use.
But that's really interesting to me.
But jfk had this,
this idea of built in him from
childhood,
as you were saying about hating
communism.
Mlk had some association,
at least with sort of loosely communism
or socialism or certainly had issues
with the United States government and
certain levels of capitalism.
So they did have.
They were at loggerheads in some way.
Yeah,
I think kennedy did not want to get
burned by king.
In other words,
he didn't want to kind of bring king
into his inner circle.
And then king manifests himself as a
flaming communist kennedy.
It was way too cool a character to get
burned that way.
But by the summer of [inaudible] 63.
So after the birmingham crisis,
which was the national outrage on
television,
can I get heckled and his speeches?
Hey,
you're not doing anything about civil
rights.
And that's when he really pushed the tax
cut in that august and september nine,
63.
Which is when the march on Washington
happen,
and let's remember the subtitle of the
march on Washington,
martin luther king,
a Philip Randolph was march on
Washington,
was the march on Washington for jobs and
freedom and those are the two sides of
kennedy's legislative agenda,
tax cut.
Civil rights act.
Kennedy actually felt,
we believe that if you had the tax cut
early enough,
you wouldn't even need the civil rights
act.
So that's the way kind of kennedy
walkthrough this going to complicated
politics.
So he really sounds to me sort of like a
politician's politician.
He doesn't sound much like an ideolog
specifically,
and that he really was listening to the
people about him.
Is there anything else that we're
missing to sort of get the full picture
on the way he tried to govern?
Yeah,
I mean he got lucky too,
and I hate to use that word in this
context.
I'm the most outrageous event in the
history of the rights movement.
Might be the birmingham birmingham
church bombing and September,
1963 when the four girls were killed by
dynamite,
um,
that actually made kennedy's tax cut
because the event was so outrageous.
Case tax bill was being voted on in
congress.
Right.
Then the southern democrats did not feel
like they could make a show of defeating
kennedy's legislation because that event
was so outrageous and then it slipped
through the house and passed right
there.
So the birmingham church bombing
actually had a lot to do with the
passage of the kennedy tax cut.
That's interesting.
So yeah,
I know kennedy,
he was okay as a legislator,
but I mean he got away with a lot too.
And he got,
he got a little lucky.
Interesting.
So speaking of luck,
let's talk about the cuban missile
crisis.
Got a little bit,
because I guess this really is the.
well,
I guess you would argue that the tax
guides really are his biggest legacy,
but I think most people think of the
cuban missile crisis.
Uh,
so just to kind of set the stage.
Sure.
Well,
I just want to point out in terms of his
legislative agenda,
I don't think it's disputable,
but the tax cut was his most important
legacy.
Maybe the civil rights act,
but yeah,
when it comes to foreign policy,
we're talking about two different
ballgames.
Yeah,
like even as a grad and now that played
right to kennedy's strength,
I'm afraid because if it was going to be
clarified,
there's going to be a contest between
the us and the representative communism,
the soviet union,
the us was going to win so that that
played right into his hands so that we
know that that's built into him from
child.
Just give me a cuban missile.
Crisis was kind of one on one,
a little bit about wHat led up to what
his decision making was.
That showed a piece of wonder.
So nikita khrushchev is the premier of
the soviet union and they use new client
states and Cuba.
If ever since fidel castro had taken
over in 59 and a.
He khrushchev sent nuclear missiles to
Cuba,
so there'd be 90 miles away from us
territory in Florida.
When this is discovered,
a kennedy tells the soviets they have to
get out immediately.
[inaudible]
has done a great tension,
could lead to the firing of missiles in
kennedy,
gets khrushchev to face down.
Kennedy gets him to say,
okay,
we'll pull our missiles out,
and it was Big akan christians face back
in the soviet union.
One tidbit about that,
the documents that came out in november
on the presidential assassination do
seat just this past november,
the last couple of months ago,
do seem to indicate that khrushchev gave
the order after that humiliation to all
networks globally.
The kennedy should be assassinated and
lee harvey oswald may have begun his
preparations because of that director.
Wow.
All right,
so I do want to talk about the
assassination.
Obviously even just the way you said
that there's so much of it that it's
hard to piece together.
And how far do you want to go down the
rabbit hole and filed the conspiracies
and all that,
but we will get to that.
But what.
What was the final Moment that got
khrushchev to turn down?
I mean,
did kennedy basicaLly say,
well,
I know there's the line of course,
but was it really communicated like this
is going to be world war three?
I thinK to answer that question,
um,
we have to speak russian and have access
to the archives because I think what
happened is that crew chef felt pressure
at home.
Um,
as a lot of people have said,
the soviet union really was the status
quo power in the politburo began asking
khrushchev,
um,
are you going to take our lives away
from us?
You're going to take our summer docos on
the caspian sea away from us and our,
our 10 percent of us in the soviet union
who have a nice life.
Um,
what are you doing?
Would you please Back down?
it seems that whatever kennedy was
doing,
the real folding happened on the soviet
side.
And chris,
jeff was not the first among equals.
I mean,
he did not.
He was barely premier of the soviet
union.
So it seems that,
and we don't have enough information on
this because it's behind the source
walls that the russians backed down
because they realized khrushchev was
acting crazy.
Yeah.
This may sound like an amateur question,
but did they ever actually speak the two
of them through translators?
Was there ever or everything goes
through the communication for review.
There's a great book on this called one
hell of A gamble,
uh,
which has all the documents is amazing
book by ernest may and phil zelikow
from,
from the 1990.
So let's look that up.
How much after the cuban missile crisis,
I mean,
that really changed everything in
american foreign policy,
right?
I mean,
it really was a huge catalyst for a lot.
Well,
we argue in our book,
um,
that the,
the big change foreign policy wise came
a year later when kennedy countenanced
assisted in the assassination of the
south vietnamese president's am in
november,
just a couple of weeks before kennedy's
assassination.
And that seems to have been the tipping
point in Vietnam.
I'm telling you,
I've been listening to a lot of the
kennedy tapes on Vietnam with mcnamara
and everything else.
It is true that kennedy had no real
interest in a longterm war in southeast
asia and no,
he didn't.
What on earth he was doing helping to
assassinate cme and I have no idea and
that was a big mistake.
So was that really just because he had
this again,
he had this thing drilled him from his
father
from childhood about communism and maybe
that overrode the intellectual part of
him that said,
let's not get into these intractable
wars.
Yeah,
I think.
I think gm and Vietnam was one of those
people that madden kennedy,
because he didn't like king.
He didn't want you to bring him into,
into his circle.
And then have you burned him?
Tim was an american guy.
Yeah.
He's our guy in south Vietnam and he
just kept alienating people and making
life difficult for the monks scenario
and kennedy's like,
hey,
you're supposed to be our guy.
And um,
John F.
Kennedy.
So at some point kennedy will break and
just said,
okay,
you're gone.
Gone.
And this meant that.
Fascinated and that is rare in the
kennedy ambit,
um,
and it ended up being not good for
american and vietnamese fortunes for the
next 10 years.
Yeah.
What else do we need to know about your
sort of,
the personal side in terms of what was
going on in the white house during those
years?
Yeah,
I mean he ran an elegant white house and
all that.
He did have his Kids.
Girlfriends really kind of did that,
that side of him to desecrate the white
house and I think we have to understand
what you mean.
well,
no,
I think it's hard for people to
understand in a modern sense of what
could it be for social media before
everyone had a phone and all that.
Like what did the average person know
about that at the time or what was the
media even saying about that?
Well,
I kind of the wisdom of crowds.
I think the electorate largely
understood what was going on even though
there's no hard evidence in the papers
and so forth.
And there really wasn't any hard
evidence.
I mean,
now we know about his swimming nude and
this is what the pools and the secret
service having to hold his drinks and
all that stuff and we know all about
that now when judith exner may have been
killed by the communists because she was
a plant and all that.
Judith exner,
but give her punches.
Nice.
Um,
I believe that because kennedy had so
many kind of crazy affairs in the white
house,
the press felt that it was burned,
like we're not allowed to report this.
And that's really what gave us water k
because nixon's things were kind of
small in comparison.
And the press just like we got burned
them,
we're not going to get burned again.
Wow.
That's fascinating.
I've never heard anyone lay it out like
that.
So basically they kind of played along
with jfk because they were trying to be
nice.
Maybe he was a little bit of their guys
sort of.
But then,
and if they felt embarrassed by it,
I mean they felt used.
I mean we're just shutting up about
this.
And then the next time a suggestion of
that came around,
they just went with a sledge hammer.
Interesting.
That's really interesting.
Sorry.
So obviously we have to talk about the
assassination.
Tell me a little bit just in the weeks
leading up to it and what was going on
in the presidency.
Yeah,
I think that was really kennedy's
highest time as president thurston
clarke has written a great book about
kennedy's last hundred days from august
to November,
1963.
But he really was coming into his own.
And I think that's true actually.
He kept talking to the secret service
agent.
Hey,
isn't this a great day to Be alive?
I mean,
he was really into it.
um,
his tax that was going through.
So [inaudible] was going through,
the soviets were gone.
He just says that's a footnote.
So how public was that by the way?
Was that.
Oh,
it was public.
It was completely public.
Well,
no,
it was presented as a palace coup that
it was internal.
So the american fingerprints were not
clear at the time.
And his ambassador is new ambassador
henry cabot lodge,
uh,
who defeated in the senate race and
fifties was kind of the fall guy,
so it appears that he put somebody in
and sat in saigon who would have to
endure the dirty work.
So aside from that,
kennedy's enjoying watching polo,
horace mitchell missile launches and
he's laughing at the senate finance
committee,
which is trying to hold up his tax cut
and it sounds like you guys keep trying
to hold it up,
but you know,
I'm going to win.
So he's really kind of coming into his
own.
And then November 22nd.
So what was it,
you know,
how to ask this question properly
because you see everyone seen so much
about it,
but the new starts breaking and it's
hard to imagine what breaking news would
be like at that time.
Now,
can you kind of frame that a little bit?
We can see these.
They're on youtube.
Um,
so we,
soap operas back then were,
were alive.
So they will be live actors acting out
the soap opera and they were broken
into.
and you can watch this again and on the
internet right now,
uh,
with bulletins from wall,
from a walter cronkite and so forth,
uh,
saying that,
there's been an incident,
dallas President's been shot and then
they would go back to the live acting
and then the actors would just start
acting again about the drama of the soap
opeRa.
But it took about probably about 45
minutes to an hour for people to realize
that that happened here.
When the,
the conspiracies start popping like
immediately where people go,
something is wrong here,
you know,
why was he taking this sort of circular
route and around with the topless card
and all of that stuff.
Like people immediately doing that.
Well,
yeah.
I mean the trip to dallas itself was
controversial.
It was in the planning in october,
november because dallas was a hotbed of
kind of what we might call white
supremacy.
And people worry.
Well,
and kennedy said it's not country down
there.
They're kind of anticandida even though
they voted for kennedy because of
johnson on the ticket.
so everyone was worried about his not
getting a good reception in Texas from
the,
kind of called them racist,
you know,
whites,
if you want to use those terms.
But the trip was totally successful on
those counts.
He went to fort worth and a huge
celebration and he went to dallas and
everyone loved them in the last words,
perhaps spoken to John F.
Kennedy were from connally's wife in the
car.
Well,
it's all over now and you can't say the
Texas doesn't love you.
And then he was blown away.
Wow.
Incredible.
So,
you know,
I think the first time that I
paid at the end,
the attention to this was probably in
high school when I saw the movie,
jfk.
Uh,
I assume you've seen the video.
So how far is as someone that really
cares about this story and all that,
I mean,
how far down all these rabbit holes are
you willing to go?
It sounds like some of it's still
unfolding as new documents still come
out,
but just for you as someone that is
interested in this.
Yeah,
I mean I think,
um,
there are a couple aspects of the
assassination that we have to take
seriously,
that we have to kind of lose our
sophistication about,
oh,
oswald acted alone.
Now hold it up.
Dealey plaza is the best place possible
for an assassination.
That's where it happened.
That should interest us in terms of
conspiracy theories.
Can you,
can you explain why?
I mean there's that slow turn as the
points of vision.
Oh,
it's at the end of the parade routes to
the parade is over and then there has to
be a right turn and a left turn that
goes then downhill.
So the parade's over,
which means the intensity of the
experiences over in the secret services,
um,
interest will start to wane.
And that was absolutely essential in the
assassination.
Then.
So there's that setting in those,
the school book depository right there
with an aggressive goal and an overpass
to stemmons freeway.
And um,
well it's a perfect place for
assassination.
So therefore we should stop this pseudo
sophistication about,
oh,
alice world acted alone.
The other thing too is kennedy was
absurdly good at making enemies.
I mean,
he just made enemies,
his father made enemies for a living.
So
by the way,
we've talked for 45 or 50 minutes and we
haven't even said in military industrial
complex one.
We obviously had some sort of issues
with him,
which we can touch on it though,
right?
So,
um,
so,
and oswald also had connections to beat
the band with the mob.
The soviets,
cubans,
you know,
I mean,
so that's also very fruitful.
Jack ruby oswald was killed.
Jack ruby has connections to beat the
band.
So these are all suggestive nonetheless.
James pearson's book,
camelot and the cultural revolution is
the best book ever written,
but about the kennedy assassination in.
It is about the liberal reaction to the
kennedy assassination because liberals
to this day have pinned it on the white
supremacists in dallas.
And that's just crazy.
He was killed because he was a con
because he was an anticommunist.
I mean,
that's pretty clear that lee harvey
oswald killed John F.
Kennedy because John F.
Kennedy was anticommunist and we now are
starting to piece together that he may
have felt he was acting on orders from
the soviet union.
We may have felt.
That's an interesting way of phrasing
it.
What do you mean may have felt
well?
Oswald was quite a character and what
was going on in his head.
We don't know.
We do know that he met.
He went to the cube,
the cuban embassy to me,
to soviet assassination expert in
september 19,
63.
The documents that just came out imply
that it was understood in late 1962,
that nikita khrushchev,
after getting burned in the cuban
missile crisis,
may have sent out some kind of broad
order into the global soviet network
than it would be desirable if president
at states were assassinated in that
order may have been called back because
of pressure within the politburo at
chris chef,
you're still acting like a nut.
Khrushchev was forced out in 1964,
but once you squeeze the toothpaste out
of the tube,
it's done hard to get it back in.
So it may be,
this is speculation,
but grounded in some sources that oswald
was part of that initial outreach and
then may not have stopped and then went
ahead with it.
So basically you're willing to go down
these,
these routes.
You sort of have to do that.
The more I read about this and the more
of these documentaries I watched,
you know,
I've got across the and book right there
and I always quote,
you know,
extraordinary claims require
extraordinary evidence.
So I don't know that we have the
extraordinary evidence,
but there were so many pieces in play
here that,
that make it seem hard to believe.
I think the one thing that is firming up
pretty well is that oswald killed
kennedy because he perceived kennedy to
be anticommunist.
So it was the left that killed kennedy
because kennedy was too right wing,
um,
that's been lost over the last 50 some
years.
That is firming up through a lot of
sources.
that's the most important thing.
I think to conclude then with the deep
story of oswald's connections are okay.
That's interesting.
From the grassy knoll.
No,
there's no shot from the grassy knoll.
It's impossible.
Anyone's been a dealer.
Plaza realizes that's a physical
impossibility.
All that stuff.
It does appear very clearly that oswald
fire,
those bullets hit the traffic light.
Then he hit kennedy in the neck.
Then he had kennedy and the dha.
The magic bullet.
That's very easy to see with a heavy
case bullet.
Full metal jacket.
Yeah.
That will act that way.
The ballistics aren't a question.
Oswald shot kennedy.
What was it like after the few weeks
after the assassination?
Johnson was disoriented.
Um,
you know,
his staff of kennedy's people wanted to
resign.
They didn't like johnson.
I'm the one thing he realized though,
is that,
uh,
I have to act to make,
to memorialize kennedy.
And the one specific step he took was he
told the senate,
guess what you're doing?
You're passing his tax cut right now,
which they did because he could
intimidate the senate.
That gave us the tax cut of 1964 and
then kennedy's promise was fulfilled in
that five percent growth kept cruising
through the sixties.
What waS the general,
even taking it away from the political
side,
the general feeling in the country after
that?
Yeah.
Um,
this whole thing about lost innocence,
uh,
I was just in fort worth a couple of
weeKs ago and I can't believe fort worth
and dallas have a big rivalry.
Fort worth thinks as much better than
tantalus reds 30 miles away.
And uh,
everywhere in fort worth there are these
reminders of kennedy's last,
uh,
moments when America was innocent.
We're in fort worth and then he went to
dallas where he was killed.
Um,
so that myth of american innocence is
perpetuated.
I don't think it's particularly a,
makes a lOt of sense in terms of.
First of all,
kennedy was killed because he was
anticommunist.
So I know the narrative makes sense on
that grounds too.
And I mean,
look,
the civil rights movement,
which was a great benefit to the United
States,
will then push through and flourished
after 1963.
So that kind of lost innocence I've
never quite understood.
So basically the three markers really
are the economic stuff,
the tax guides,
the civil rights stuff,
and the cuban missile crisis.
Is there anything else we're missing in
there that that's important?
Well,
the Vietnam,
I mean,
kennedy would have never let Vietnam be.
The disaster was.
He would have never let that happen.
So oliver stone is completely wrong.
That,
uh,
you know,
that kenny was killed by right wingers
who,
one of the Vietnam war.
But uh,
it is,
I think in escapable to conclude that
kennedy would not have presided over the
Vietnam wars like johnson did.
yeah.
I'm curious as a historian and someone
that deeply cares about this stuff,
when you see all of these movies,
I mean we make everything into movies
now rather jfk and there's lincoln,
everything now there's like 18 winston
churchill stuff.
How much does that concern you?
Like at some level it's great.
people are getting basic ideas about
this stuff.
But then in the case of the jfk movie,
which I really loved by the way,
and I can,
as you can see,
I can play those conspiracy games,
but that it also is hinting at,
you know,
there's a real implication that,
that johnson maybe had something to do
with it in the jfk movie and read all
that stuff.
So how much does that worry you that we
get all of our information now from
movies and documentaries and all that
history is cult like having a history
originated in the stone age,
around campfires.
Tell me stories about them.
And it's not a closeted academic
subject.
I mean,
academics have a lot to say,
but there has to be very,
you know,
good interaction,
healthy interaction between all of these
kinds of so called vulgar forms of
history,
which are wonderful,
uh,
better in certain ways and academic
history.
Um,
I just thought all of a sudden it's
great movie maker.
I mean,
I love his movies and platoon is
incredible movie the others.
But he has an ax to grind about Vietnam.
I mean,
it was the capitalist who gave it to us.
It was the right to gave it to us,
know if you kept the anticommunist
presidents and you've got to realize he
was anticommunist.
He would have realized how to deal with
that crisis.
Hmm.
Alright.
So to wrap this all up,
I thought that the right way to end this
would be.
We've talked a little bit about the sort
of modern day context and the modern day
lens on some of this stuff and you've
referenced how sort of the parties have
kind of flipped some of the things that
jfk was saying then would not be things
that democrats would say.
Now,
what do you think his political
alignments would be these days if John
F.
Kennedy had lived?
I don't think the democratic party would
have flipped.
So let's say John F.
Kennedy has two term presidency.
Somehow we don't really have Vietnam
war.
He is ex president,
1969.
Um,
to the democrats spend the next 20,
30 years saying that kennedy tax cut had
nothing to do with cutting the top
right.
No.
He would've been forced discipline on
that conversation in the democrats would
have been born along as the party of tax
cuts.
So that investment flows into the real
world and there are lots of jobs for the
regular guy.
So no,
I think that the democratic party would
have been a lot different than if he had
lived.
Wow.
so,
so he really was the lay's.
is it fair to say then you think that he
was sort of the last,
somewhat small democrat,
small government democrat at some level?
yeah.
I think what happened is that the left
took advantage of the assassination
because kennedy wasn't around to defend
himself specifically because of the
assassination.
The left said,
aha,
we can misrepresent his record,
we can hold him high,
some kind of Big government liberal.
And then he became that and caroline and
john john.
We're kind of enough to go along with
that ted certainly.
And that became the icon of John F.
Kennedy.
John kennedy himself would have never
let that happen.
So I'm trying to place where he would be
at right now.
And I'm guessing.
sorry.
So if he was basically for tax cuts,
he believed in a strong military at some
level because he was fighting communism
yet also at all these issues with the
military and industrial complex.
I'm trying to figure out what,
how would you frame that type of
political person these days?
It's like sort of libertarian,
but then with a little bit of a neo-con
yeah.
Well these days would be very different.
I don't even thinK we would have had
bill clinton because kennedy would have
been around to be the elder party leader
and people wouldn't have been able to
get away with a lot of the
misrepresentation that they have in
order to make the modern democratic
party.
That's interesting.
So the assassination and then
subsequently the whole family sort of
falling apart and Robert Kennedy and
everything else and I mean that really
did set it,
set the nation in a strange way,
but it really did something crazy to the
democratic party inherently because it's
holding machine.
Yeah,
sorT of.
You mentioned rfk.
Yeah.
Rfk probably was going to have another
marginal tax cut a.
Then he's blown away in 1968.
Ted kennedy continue to talk about tax
cuts through the mid seventies and then
only in 1980 became this kind of big
status,
a government type.
So yeah,
we could have.
It could have been a lot different if
the kennedy boys had lived.
Yeah.
Do you think we're done with the
dynasties?
I mean it seems to be now that you know,
hillary lost,
so it seems like perhaps we've had our
last clinton,
although I'm sure chelsea is going to
run for senator from New York or
something like that.
You know,
the bush family really after jeb did so
horribly.
It seems like that might be done.
Although George Bush down in Texas,
maybe we'll do something.
Maybe trump iS goIng to step aside and
let ivanka run next time or who knows,
but I sense that the dynasty thing
really has people's sort of exhaustion,
you know,
with families that have this much power
really has reached a peak and that would
seem to be a celebrity as phenomenon.
I think again,
the assassination is at fault here.
If John F.
Kennedy had had two full terms,
would the nation have felt the
obligation to find out about all these
other kennedy's?
Probably not,
but the cutting short of that political
career,
I think is what gave life to all these
other kennedy's running for office.
Wow.
It's fascinating stuff.
Well,
I've thoroughly enjoyed this.
We're going to put the link to your
book.
Write down below.
So for more on jfk,
his life and legacy checkout.
Brian's book,
jfk,
and the reagan revolution,
a secret history of american prosperity,
which again,
we're going to link to write down below.